from the middle of her hair she sees two
snakes and through them were
pestilential hand the snakes terrified
the hearts of Eno and a thermos and
breathed sickness into their minds when
it came to dealing with crimes in
ancient Greece the majority of
punishments were left to the individual
states but there were some exceptions
petty crimes such as theft were normally
ignored by the gods however when it came
to crimes against the gods or matricide
and patricide the murder of one's mother
and father the gods would then intervene
it was rare for the gods to personally
pursue the guilty instead they enlisted
the services of the arenas or the Furies
as they were sometimes referred to the
ER in knees were the three goddesses of
vengeance and retribution and they would
be responsible for pursuing and
punishing those for their crimes against
the natural order they were created when
the Titan Cronus castrated his father
Uranus his genitals were thrown into the
sea thus creating Aphrodite and the
blood that dripped down onto Gaia the
earth created the ironies the actual
amount of irony that were born is
unknown but the three best known or
Alecto the unceasing mogera the grudging
and tisha ffunny the vengeful
destruction it's because of these three
that when we refer to the arenas they
are seen as a trio with the arenas
essentially be in the police force of
the gods we can look at these three as
the three Chiefs in charge
it wasn't just the gods that could
summon the arenas it was believed that
any victim could call down the curse of
the arena upon a criminal the most
powerful curse was that placed by a
parent on their child as the arenas are
born of a similar crime with Cronus
castrating his father the murder of
one's mother and father was considered
the worst crime in the eyes of the
ironies one of their first appearances
was in Homer's Iliad where they were
Punishers of oath breakers and they
embodied the curses of parents who had
been wronged by their children the
ironies Roth would manifest itself in
several different ways
murderers would often suffer illness and
disease cities that were found harboring
criminals would share in the punishment
with disease hunger and death spreading
amongst its people until the fugitive
was given up the arenas were known for
endlessly pursuing criminals and
tormented them until they were driven
insane for those being pursued by the
arenas the only alternative to being
driven insane was atonement a process
that involved complete in a series of
labors followed by a purification ritual
the arenas were often depicted as rather
ugly winged women not too different from
the appearance of a harpy but unlike the
harpies the arenas had poisonous
serpents entwined in their hair arms and
waist they could often be seen as wooden
a whip as a weapon and the clothing they
wore often differed sometimes were in
long black robes and other times short
length skirts and boots similar to that
of a Huntress
the ironies was said to lend their
services to Hades and Persephone in the
underworld they would aid in torturing
criminals locked away in the dungeons of
the Damned
one of the most well-known stories that
features the arenas is one that we
partly touched on when discussed in the
story of Iphigenia our brother our
easties had slain his mother because she
had slain her husband for the sacrifice
of a virgin aya committing the crime of
matricide meant that arrestees was
tormented by the ironies this letter
easties to seek the help of the Oracle
of Delphi
he was told to go to Athens and ask the
goddess Athena for a trial during the
trial the ironies appeared as the
accusers of our easties who were eager
to spill his blood the trial ended in a
split decision with Athena having the
costume vote she decided to acquit their
asti's of all of his crimes
as expected the written news did not
agree with the decision of the goddess
and they threatened torment and a plague
upon the people of Athens after a long
negotiation with Athena the ironies
eventually changed their mind it was
after this discussion but they would no
longer be the Irenaeus protectors of
vengeance they became the semi
protectors of justice if you guys
enjoyed this video then go ahead and
leave it a like and let me know what you
thought in the comments below for those
of you who don't know I've recently
started a second channel where I'll be
uploading a couple times a week
hopefully the channel itself is gonna be
a storytelling channel mix of some kind
of ASMR elements so if you like a s more
or you like storytelling then I'll leave
a link in the description and there'll
be an end screen that you can click on
go ahead and check it out and give it a
sub if that's something you're
interested in as always I've been your
host mythology in fiction explained